-Our first guest tonight
is a Golden Globe-winning actor
you know from such films
as "Moulin Rouge!"
and the "Star Wars" prequels
as well as his Emmy-nominated
work in the FX series "Fargo."
He stars in "Christopher Robin",
which is in theaters tomorrow.
Let's take a look.
-This place is very big.
Do you live here all alone?
-Just now, yes,
but usually, no.
My wife and daughter
are in the countryside
for the weekend.
-Well, why -- [ grunts ] --
aren't you with them?
-Well --
[ Sighs ]
-Sticky business.
-I had to say for work.
Why are you here and not
in the forest with your friends?
That's the question.
-Well, I couldn't find anybody.
I couldn't find anyone, either.
And I looked for them both --
Hello?
-[ Sighs ]
Piglet?
Eeyore?
Tigger?
Where is everybody?
-Exactly.
Where is Tigger or Kanga or Roo?
-That's why I'm here.
-Please welcome back to the show
Ewan McGregor, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-So lovely to have you back.
-I'm glad to be here.
Very nice.
-This is very exciting,
you are --
For those who couldn't figure
it out from the clip...
-Yeah.
-...you're an adult
Christopher Robin.
-Yes.
A grown-up Christopher Robin.
-That's very exciting.
-Yeah, it's nice.
It's nice to take someone that
we know iconically like that,
like, a young --
I've done it the other way.
In the "Star Wars" films,
I took an older character,
who was iconic, and tried
to play him as a younger man.
And this time, it's the reverse.
-Yeah, that's --
-Yeah.
-You'll have to let me how
this one works out for you.
-Yeah, we'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
-And, obviously, an incredible
amount of CGI in this film.
-Yes.
Well, yes.
It's so funny, because
I remember it like that.
Like, I remember,
we had a little Winnie the Pooh
who was like a Teddy bear.
He wasn't a puppet or
he wasn't animated in any way.
-'Cause you couldn't get
the real Winnie the Pooh, right?
He turned down the project.
-He was too -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
-He was too expensive.
-Yeah, of course.
-That's the problem.
But we had
this little Teddy bear,
and then, a Teddy bear
for each of the creatures.
And Marc Forster,
our brilliant director,
cast this group
of enthusiastic young actors,
most of them
just out of drama school,
to play each of the creatures.
So when we were playing a scene,
you know, they would be there
with the Teddy bear.
They'd move him around
and do the voice
and act with us in the scenes.
And then improvise.
We wanted to go away
from the text and improvise.
They would improvise with us,
and they were brilliant.
And I got used
to his little face,
because he looked
just like that.
I mean, it was like acting
with a little bear.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So when I watched the film
for the first time, I sort of --
I kept having to remind myself
that he wasn't there on the day.
[ Laughter ]
-Right, yeah.
-'Cause it's just sort of
how I remember it.
And because we know
the characters so well,
I could imagine how he might be.
But they did him so beautifully.
-It's really wonderful.
And the voice is someone
who voiced him in the 1980
"Winnie the Pooh" cartoons.
-Jim Cummings.
-Yeah, which is incredibly nice
to hear such a familiar voice.
It would be weird
if Winnie the Pooh
sounded different.
-Someone else, yes.
-If he had, like,
a thick New York accent,
it would be a huge --
[ Laughter ]
-Or Scottish.
-Yeah, Scottish, yeah.
-[ Scottish accent ]
Christopher!
Christopher Robin!
-[ Scottish accent ]
Get your head out of your ass!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
That was very good.
Oh, thank you very much.
I can't believe I had the nerve
to do my B-minus
Scottish impression
in front of you.
-That was really good, yeah.
-But now, you would think
a child would be excited
to come on set and see these
actors holding these puppets.
But some of the puppets
would maybe freak out a child
if they came.
-Yes. We had --
The truth is, we had the
beautiful finished product,
the lovely bear to act with.
And it was for
the visual effects people
to see what he looked like
in the light and everything.
But they couldn't animate him
on top of that hairy bear,
so we had --
[ Laughter ]
I just said "hairy bear"
on television.
-Yeah.
-But we had --
[ Laughter ]
-A lot of people who were, like,
in the kitchen
and had totally tuned this out,
were like, "Oh!"
-"Wait a minute."
[ Laughter ]
So they had a gray --
Just a canvas bear with no hair.
And they, I guess,
they would animate him
on top of that gray bear.
But they also sometimes
needed one without a head.
So you'd do takes
with the gray headless bear.
[ Laughter ]
And then,
there was a real horror show one
where it was just his torso --
no arms, legs, or head.
And it was like the
Guillermo del Toro version.
[ Laughter ]
And then they had an arm
on a stick, a Pooh --
A Pooh on a stick.
They had an arm...
[ Laughter ]
...on a stick.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And they had his little feet
on sticks, as well,
for the little footstep shots
and stuff so...
-See, that's all haunting.
-Yeah.
-Although, they could
use the torso and do a sequel
where Tigger comes and says,
"Something awful's happened."
[ Laughter ]
-"I lost my mind.
I don't know what I --"
-"I don't know."
-"I don't know what I did."
-"I did something.
I woke up, I did something!"
[ Laughter ]
Have you read the books?
Is that something --
-Yes. I mean,
I read them to all my girls.
The first one, anyway.
There's a series
of four or five books.
But I'm familiar
with the first volume.
And then I'm sure I must have
been read it when I was a kid,
'cause I'm so familiar
with those stories.
-And then this sort of --
this film takes place
post-World War II.
And did the timing
of when this was happening
inform how you wanted to play
Christopher Robin?
-Yeah.
I love that era.
I watched quite a lot film --
I watched a lot of
early Alec Guinness films.
There's a great film called
"Man in a White Suit"
that I watched.
-Mm-hmm.
-And there's a British film
I watched,
"From Here to Eternity."
[ Proper British accent ]
And anything where everyone
spoke like that.
You know.
-Yeah.
-"Are you happy, darling?"
"Terribly."
That kind of thing.
[ Normal voice ]
And there was one film
that was very handy to me.
There's a film called
"Genevieve."
-Okay.
-Which was about
a vintage car race
in the early '50s or late '40s.
And that one was --
the main character in that
is quite like Christopher Robin.
-That's nice that you got to --
that's a very wonderful thing
to be able to do research
for your work
that is just, like,
watching cool old movies.
-Watching old films.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I grew up
watching those old films.
And so there's --
I feel like I've been waiting
to play this kind of guy
for a long time.
-When you were young
and watching films like that,
were other people your age
watching films like that?
Because that seems a little...
[ Light laughter ]
-I don't think --
Well, I don't know.
On the weekends, on BBC Two,
they'd have like matinees
on a Saturday and Sunday, they'd
play two old films back to back.
And I would always be propped up
on my elbows watching them.
But I don't know.
I didn't --
-I do think that I,
looking back,
I saw a lot of old films because
there was nothing else on.
-Yeah.
-And Netflix didn't exist.
-That's right.
-Yeah.
-So you'd be like,
"You tell me, TV."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, "What is it?"
-"Yeah, it's up to you."
-"What's it gonna be today?"
Yeah, exactly.
No, that's right.